what are the biggest issues that you're
seeing in the dating Marketplace trying
to date as a single woman like what sort
of roadblocks are you running up against
I want to say well I'm extremely picky
anyway so it's just that's problematic
in and of itself but
um
I want to say like effort like the whole
mindset of The Grass Is Always Greener
that's kind of a thing like you can hit
it off Match whatever
have a good thing and then it just
dissipates
so effort on their part they're not
continuing with the same effort that
started with the first few dates yeah
okay what do you think that is
um well it's a little bit different now
that I live in Wisconsin the dating
environment's a lot different that's a
lot different from Tampa isn't it like
Wisconsin's very very different from
Florida Yeah so basically my type isn't
in Wisconsin so something that I'm
dealing with now is people obviously
don't like long distance was it a
relocation you had to do from Florida up
there
yeah it was for work okay so the so the
work deal was that good that you had to
take it
yeah I was kind of hoping that the
relationship aspect wasn't going to be
as hard as it is but
were you in a relationship when you
moved up to Wisconsin like did you have
a conversation like I have to go here do
you want to come or you were single at
the time no I was single okay
okay so it's an effort component from
him on your own today you're recently
single it's been a month
have you been dating or
I've been dating
um
what what are you seeing
there's a lot of great guys online
um
you can meet guys in person I think the
problem is you know
They Don't Really check all the boxes
sometimes so
uh
it's like
yeah it's like a lack of effort or the
bare minimum sometimes you feel like is
what's going on there
um
what do you mean by check all the boxes
like what are the what do the boxes look
like
what are the boxes that need to get
checked
um
give us like your five give us like your
top five boxes yeah let's keep it simple
like five
I have a lot of books
give us your best five what are the what
are the deal breakers I said
non-negotiables
um so in what regard like
our ability to communicate physically
financially like there's several
different things pick your best yeah
pick your best five like let's say we
give you five and you're trying to
perform the best guy you can like give
me your five uh over six feet
minimum
um
good looking right Knees Down rich
uh
be good looking highly masculine
um can you define highly masculine
I would say very confident
um
can kind of understand women not
desperate and not a jerk like just kind
having empathy
personable easy to communicate with
funny
so I would say yeah it's like confident
calibrated and
calibrate is a good word yeah calibrated
the calibrated when you talk about
understanding women I think calibrated
or we kind of call that like RP
awareness but so we have six foot good
looking highly masculine so you have
three so you have two more
I would say shared interests
um I'm working on a novel right now
would be great if someone could discuss
literature with me and be an A plus
um I'm pretty well read
um a pattern and with my exes is
we could discuss literature and
philosophy and things like that we had
common interests
and then the last one I guess
um
oh man that's tough I guess I thought
you had like 40. I know picking from all
do you want me to think about it so I
think
you're putting around the spot and
forcing her to narrow it down to five so
you gotta I think
uh strong family ties probably
okay how does that list Look to You
Chelsea is that is that your list you
have a you have a modified version of
that you want to give us your top five
um so when she says very masculine
that's one of mine
um
height I'm not so strict with like I
tend to like guys who are
big and strong not necessarily the six
foot line
um because how tall are you Chelsea
you're five two yeah I'll tell you uh
Janae I'm 5 10. okay so that I'll
explain six foot
so five two five ten
so you said very masculine sorry Chelsea
there's four more
so
I can get along with
also want someone
has very much lived like a different
life for me so I can learn from them
um I don't like people who are too much
like me because then we're just boring
can we can we call that captivation can
we call it captivating
somebody with a different life yeah okay
captivating
someone who can also
can be
like mature and everything but can also
like play video games and have fun and
lay back
so mature and playful
okay you got one more
um
intelligent
I have a question why didn't money show
up in that for either of you like
success wealth
so for me personally I never
really cared that much about that aspect
as long as they were
you know not
broke per se but like what's broke like
doesn't have a job under 70 000 under a
hundred thousand like what do you
consider broke um doesn't have a job
can't take care of themselves
okay but I mean like you could have a
guy in Wisconsin making probably forty
five thousand dollars a year that has a
job that takes care of himself is that
is that enough
for a long-term relationship with you
I don't think so
but I don't necessarily have a standard
that you have to make this much in order
for us so
is the plan to have a family like you
want to have kids you want to get
married
no I want to get myself you want to get
married but no kids yeah definitely no
kids definitely no kids debt like 100
definite one thousand percent never
happening doctor says I can tie your
tubes tomorrow you're let's let's go do
it
I wouldn't want to tie my tubes
necessarily just in case I meet someone
and that changes but like oh no
okay so there's so there is a potential
to change it so money uh for Eugene I
didn't didn't matter didn't show up is
there a line right
what's the goal because I mean you're
you know you're 29 you're an account
you're successful you're looking for
somebody literate that's into literature
that you can have a little bit of banter
with back and forth are you looking to
get married like what's what's the point
absolutely I want to get married you
didn't have kids or no kids kids yeah
100 gotta have kids so isn't his
financial resources important to you
because I mean you've painted the
picture I mean only painting five I know
you have 40 or 30.
I don't think I'm better than just
because I have centers I don't you know
I don't think I'm better than other
people just because I have standards for
standards are important like I think
everybody should have standards in fact
I think most people should raise their
standards most people have very low
standards I see guys put up again when I
say guys like I deal mostly with men but
I see you guys put up with a lot of [__]
and it's mostly because they they have
very very low standards for themselves
and for other people so I think
standards are really important but so
you got six foot good looking uh highly
masculine confident not needy not a jerk
calibrated similar interests uh you
talked about because literature you like
to Banter on that and family values but
money you're talking about building a
family here who's going to be bringing
home the bacon when you're
got a three-month-old at home
the reason why I left that off is
because all of my last relationships
kind of significantly out earned me
um and I found that that didn't really
solve the issues that we had together
what what issues were you having
together with the last relationship well
the relationships went down so obviously
we had some issues can you give me some
insight on some of those issues
I mean money is really important if you
want to have kids and a family in a
household and provide for them and
protect them and feed them and clothe
them in medical care and all that sort
of stuff right
um yeah so the person I was with you is
definitely on track for
uh probably an eight-figure yearly
Revenue he was doing very well
um for himself
um with his dreams and goals and
Ambitions he was a software engineer and
he left that job to create his own
company
um and I found that that in and of
itself
I mean it's nice on paper when you think
about that would be a requirement to
starting a family I would definitely
love that weight lifted off my shoulders
and be able to be provided for
but that in and of itself isn't going to
be enough to sustain a relationship I
don't think
would you Chelsea be like you said
marriage but no kids but like would you
be in a situation or would you like to
be in a situation where you could be
provided for
yeah like looked after yeah
but I wouldn't want to fully rely on
that I'd still want my own thing
the only thing Janae would you always
have to have your own thing your own
security blanket
I always will have my own security
blanket but
um just
due to you know being born into a
certain type of family like I have
security kind of inherited but
um no I would like the man to be the
provider for sure
how many kids you want to have
me yeah uh too
what if he wants like five
or eight
I don't think that would be biologically
possible at my age but I can maybe adopt
or if he has kids already maybe we could
you know what the world record is for
the most number of kids a woman's birth
how many I'm gonna get the number not
completely right but it's in the 60s I
think it's like 61 or 60 something a
bunch of you know quadruplets and
triplets and Twins and stuff you know
throughout the pregnancies but from like
that's a lot like that's that's a lot of
babies to that's a lot of work
um
no because I because I've talked to some
guys ladies that are like yeah it's got
to be five it's got to be six it's got
to be like whatever like I wanna have an
army like there's some guys I just want
to have an army of sons and sort of
things like there's some guys out there
like that
um if you met the guy that was like
perfect ticked off all the boxes like
all 40 of the boxes let's say he ticks
off all 40 of janae's boxes and he said
oh my gosh
right that guy and he says but babe
gotta have six kids you only want to
have two this is gonna work out would
you give them the six children
bye bye
by a lot yes
I was able to
that's what you wanted we would have
that discussion I don't like I said I
don't know I'm physically capable of
having that many children if I'm almost
30 but yeah well maybe have twins or
triplets right you could have two sets
of triplets
I'd be open totally possible
you'll be open to adopting
yeah if you wanted more I think what
you're asking me is how far would I be
willing to bend to someone if they were
the right person for me how much is that
what you're asking like how much of a
sacrifice I would make for them yeah I
think what it what it takes you to is if
the guy
is that valuable where he's got all 30
or 40 boxes tick for a gal would you be
willing to give him sorry
hey there's some women I've I've come
across that have like a checklist of 237
on their laundry list it's just look
it'll keep going and going and going
sort of thing right so I mean I don't
think 40 is completely unreasonable it's
a big number I mean
what what would some of the other so
what are some of the other ones that
you've had I mean and the questions for
both the ladies so what are some of the
other boxes that you'd like to take that
you're struggling to get ticked when it
comes to dating to find this guy that
you want to marry because I mean the
question is really about finding a
husband at this point for you
someone who's actually physically active
and
more
I tend to be more into like
bodybuilding type
when you say bodybuilding like describe
uh the type of physics
that you like because you said that
you're very particular like are we
talking Olympic bodybuilder natural
bodybuilders swimmer's body runner's
body like what sort of athlete are we
talking about here
I would say like natural bodybuilder
natural bodybuilder okay I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out